- [Narrator] On the
internet the other day,
I found an animal that
looks like something
quite familiar.
- They've tried to block the road,
but outside of the road, one...
- [Narrator] Turns out, this
fluffy looking caterpillar
that looks super soft is
actually super poisonous.
So I called Dr. Wagner.
He's an entomologist up at UConn.
- [Doctor] My specialty is lepidoptera
which is the study of
butterflies and moths.
- [Narrator] This caterpillar,
it has a few names.
- Well, it's megalopyge opercularis.
Most people call this
animal the puss caterpillar,
except in the South where
many people call it the asp.
- [Narrator] These
caterpillars are distinct
because they're covered in what looks like
long soft hair.
- [Doctor] Only mammals have
true hair and then what we find
on insects are really dry scales.
Underneath those is where
the poison spines are,
they're maybe a little bit
like a hypodermic needle.
When you pet the caterpillar
it's quite a wallup.
I think of all the
caterpillars that sting,
the asp may have the most painful
and most toxic sting.
- [Narrator] That poison
can cause headaches,
swelling, nausea, blisters,
even difficulty breathing.
And in case you were
thinking that these guys
probably live deep in some jungle,
you would be wrong.
- [Doctor] They're found mostly south
of the Mason-Dixon line.
- [Narrator] So here's a new adage
to help you remember:
If it looks like Trump's
hair, you better beware.